tá chegando ao rio agora é discutir é se
isso é preciso correr quando preciso
profunda êxito china mau cheiro
assim é o android pessoal do que falar
andar que seja muito bem-vindo jamais
unger eu estraguei pelo que a
contragosto não sai muito obrigado pelo
filme que vocês deram no vídeo em 360
graus e aquilo que gostava e vocês viram
mais por isso estamos aqui para fazer
uma linha santo cindes que se senta eu
estou assim por causa disto esta
explicou maravilhoso crise nos deu faz
com que jogou mas com que as pessoas
fiquem a saber que o futuro é que vocês
estão dentro de uma casa e postiga
parece um assassino para matar vocês não
sabem o que vai acontecer eu acho que
este ano os fãs um thriller uma coisa
assim não é cantora que por ser um homem
coisas assim não é que o turista por ser
um homem atrás de vocês está no fato do
clube é esse corpitcho falar absurdos
que eu gosto
agora falta em um jogo do campeão que é
o grande por ela cair para aí vocês por
estarem a mané 32 em um quarto
eu sei que vai passar um assassinato a
sangue
nelas não há aqui nenhuma em uma
situação de fuga que não atendidos 15
vai amanhã outra não faz isso não é
pouco nelsinho não quero esconder se
irmã dela vai pagar uma gorda
a polícia estava já consegui um esconde
nem ético nunca faço disse isso no caso
junto tem um estudo feito na mão
isso não está funciona contra uma chave
eu tenho uma faca agora o papa não olha
assim pra mim eu sou tudo o que eu vivi
lá eu tenho o mais empolgado do que eu
não sei não há não há como fugir da
sombra vai conseguir encontrar o quanto
sofreu pouca procura agora um dia o
senhor e no bloco das trevas curso não é
total é isso só na família chamou a
mamãe ou sentido em qualquer corrida mas
foge foge da série
olha o teu pescoço ai meu deus
sérgio estava sempre pronto agora é o
governo nada pronto não vir já morreu
morreu este ano já cá acaba sempre assim
porque não sabe oque o próximo vídeo
chamas locke outdoors ou seja am a
fechar suas portas
dora porta época e 321 vai ficar esta
menina um beijo e tosa pra cá só outros
dentro de uma casa toda desarrumada ela
deve viver sozinha com
certeza que sim ok eu acho legal pra
olhar né
processei não não isto pneu e de
projetos
ae ela deixou que os ataques todas estão
a analisar a casa e então imensos
depósitos fogo aqui mesmo que é por isso
que a lei ela consegue falar né não
ela tem que estar por trás de mim tenham
equipes para 8 da casa é o meu forte da
ifa batatas costa aí foi foi foi sair
vai pagar pelas costas pois claro
olha só a cara deu eu não tem cara é uma
máscara vai comer as batatas assim ouviu
meu deus ela é muito burra pois isso sim
vai morrer alguém polícia uma porta e
fugir do ovo pena pois estava tudo e
ouvir isso aí ó a imagem em casa
aí eu seguro e eu não ela é outra vai
morrer agora
ela atua mais forte aqui uma pena que
escolheu o homem volta é uma sair aí vai
uma sai fica a israel que é meu por
favor tanque a data é uma senhora
segunda faca quando tinha força amiga
amiga amiga virtual contrário entra não
seja eu não vou falar nada
eu não vou falar nada lá matando dez pra
lá é burra com os maneiros ano
isso estava em poder
espero que isto está outra vez
então é isso não vamos ficar porque com
isso espero que vocês tenham buscado é
bug digam o que vocês acharam neste dois
filmes o que vocês faziam nesta situção
tentavam que matar os índios tentaram
fugir que tentavam chamar a polícia
desde quando é que o favorito fiquei
meio até a próxima